[Music]
on this Friday night hiring spree
Canada's job market Grows by Leaps and
Bounds still a lot of employers looking
for to fill positions the rise in wages
and potential ripple effect on interest
rates a fresh climb in coid cases the
message from doctors as people gather
for
Thanksgiving India's latest move against
Canada Ottawa really doesn't want this
to turn into a major international
incident how diplomatic tensions are a
blow to
business and she's a tireless champion
of indigenous kids children only get one
childhood and so we've got to be there
to make sure it's a special one the
prestigious prize bestowed upon Cindy
Blackstock obal National with far
Asser good evening the Canadian job
market is delivering jobs at a
surprising rate with a latest employment
numbers blowing past expectations today
statistics Canada says the country added
some 64,000 jobs in September more than
tripling what many economists had
predicted that growth was largely driven
by part-time work though which rose by
48,000 positions now despite the surge
Canada's jobless rate held steady at
5.5% for the third consecutive month
economists warn we shouldn't get too
excited about these latest numbers as
another bank of Canada interest rate
decision looms later this month Nita
ganguli has tonight's top story it's
been a long few months for paa Ayer as
the 26-year-old searches for a job I've
been looking for a job since summer so
let's say from the month of May up to
now I've been trying to get a full-time
job in my industry but it has been a
little difficult and I haven't landed
anything so far ay says it was easier to
find job jobs earlier this year and this
recruitment expert agrees when you go
back to the beginning of the year we
came from a market that was overheated
uh many organizations out of the
pandemic were uh hiring and even over
hiring in some instances a Slowdown in
hiring is necessary economists say to
rebalance labor markets after record low
unemployment rates earlier this year
when we look at the levels of of job
postings right now you know I'm I'm back
to that you know we were in 2019 it's
still reflective of a healthy Market uh
still a lot of employers looking to fill
positions and and we're seeing that now
and historic population growth is
helping record population growth this
year we have over 3% population growth
that we're going to see and so we're
fixing that issue about very tight labor
markets and a lot of pressure on the
labor market by adding on the supply
side but for job Seekers that's a
challenge there are job openings but
there aren't enough job openings for the
number of candidates that are now in
this country along with the 64,000 jobs
added in September we saw wage growth
coming in higher than expected at
5.3% now that figure could cause
concerns for the Bank of Canada when it
meets later this month to review
interest rates as it can contribute to
inflation and it is businesses that are
bearing the brunt of those higher wages
especially as the economy slows it's
it's a tough time and I think it's
important for organizations and
employees to really navigate this uh
together I would say it has been pretty
stressful but I just have to keep at it
till I get the job I need and till I hit
the mark n ganguli Global News
Toronto as Canadians prepare for
Thanksgiving many will feel the pain of
rising food prices but it's not the only
thing to worry about this long weekend
coid cases are on the rise and as we
know holiday Gatherings can bring
increased risk hether YX West on how to
keep your loved ones as healthy as
possible all the good show turkey
stuffing cranberries and gravy and
people crowded into a small indoor space
for Thanksgiving dinner you know weekend
uh get togethers obviously people know
what the tools are it's the fourth
holiday season since the world learned
the word coid 19 and Gatherings are once
again okay but across the country there
are also signs that this virus has not
disappeared while we had very low levels
of coid throughout the summer Nova
Scotia is seeing an increase in Co
activity over the past few weeks we're
also starting to see other viruses um
that cause infections we're seeing a
little bit of influenza we have not seen
much RSV yet but those are the ones
we're looking for mandatory mask
policies have returned to hospitals and
other healthc care settings across Nova
Scotia and BC with select hospitals in
Quebec and Ontario requiring their use
again as well the newest Co boost
boosters will also provide good
protection though in most provinces both
the coid and annual flu vaccines aren't
available until next week look I'm I'm a
healthy person I uh I tend to take care
of my immune system and I'm I believe
this is something I should talk about
with my doctor not poit not media mixed
messages misinformation and plain old
coid fatigue means vaccine hesitancy is
on the rise and although the national
advisory committee on immunization and
provincial Health officers recommend the
Co boosters as safe and effective over
the last year uptake has been low it's a
significant concern I think recent
surveys have suggested that as many as
50% of Canadians are not considering
getting vaccinated as a glass half full
sort of person I would focus on the 50%
that want to get their shots and make it
as easy as possible Co can still be a
brutal and dangerous disease for older
adults and anyone who is medically
vulnerable one to be avoided if possible
as families gather to share all that
pumpkin pie Heather urx West Global News
Calgary elections Manitoba is
apologizing to residents at an
indigenous Senior's home after a nun
dressed in religious clothing was
assigned to work at a voting booth at
the
facility was quite shocked to see that
she had an elections Manitoba badge on
and here and they took all the strength
in the world to come in here and
vote the nun was placed at the keikan
nun Center in Winnipeg home to nearly 60
residents including dozens of
residential school survivors elections
Manatoba tells global news they
sincerely regret that this occurred and
they're holding a meeting with residents
so they can do better in the future the
deadline is looming for 41 Canadian
diplomats ordered to leave India after
that country's government reportedly
gave them until October 10th to get out
it's the latest retaliation after prime
minister Justin Trudeau revealed Canada
has cred ible intelligence linking India
to the killing of a Canadian sick leader
as Tera isra reports this dramatic
reduction in staff only adds another
Rift in the Diplomatic
crisis at Canada's High Commission in
Delhi the clock is winding down most of
Canada's diplomats must be gone by
Tuesday as first reported by the
financial times India's latest move
definitely escalates the problem brings
it out into the public eye calls in a
way Canada's Bluff Canada insists it
does not want to escalate the situation
but every week There's been an
escalation travel advisories suspended
Visa applications and now a mass
expulsion with 2third of Canada's
diplomatic core ordered out Canada has a
much larger number of people there would
likely be a reduction in the numbers
India calls the allegations absurd it's
linked to the killing of Canadian sick
leader Hardeep sing nider Canada
maintains the intelligence is credible
but has not publicly revealed its
evidence I think you'll see a very very
moderate response in the coming weeks
from the from the Canadian side uh that
really looks to preserving the you know
our national interest national interests
like trade Canada exported more than1
billion in goods and services to India
last year but trade talks between both
countries are now on hold and travel
restrictions are only complicating doing
business there one of the challenges of
course is Canadian Business Leaders that
don't have a visa to to be able to
actually get to
India foreign policy experts say there
are no signs yet India will retaliate
against Canada the way China did back in
2019 by Banning canola after the arrest
of huwei executive Mong wanjo but as the
dispute drags on with India it only
complicates ottawa's plans to reduce its
Reliance on B Beijing teria isri Global
News Ottawa a 29-year-old woman has been
charged with a terrorism offense for her
alleged involvement with the so-called
Islamic State the RCMP says Amara amjad
returned to Canada from Syria in early
April she was arrested yesterday in
Milton Ontario and she was charged with
participating in activity of a terrorist
group she's been released on bail in her
next court appearance is scheduled for
November 17th Sweden says it will send
Ukraine grip fighter jets but only if
it's allowed to join NATO IID turkey and
Hungary have delayed the announcement
was made as Russian missiles hit the
heart of kke today in a deadly attack on
civilians Crystal ganing Reports and a
warning first that some images in the
story are very
graphic a second day of death and
destruction this time har City Center
was
hit a missile hit my apartment directly
I pulled out my younger son and wife my
mother and older son the 10-year-old are
still there the boys are trying to pull
him out First Responders found the child
he did not survive another family
plunged into despair another scene of
Terror refuted by Russia's press
secretary we is before reiterate that
the Russian military does not strike
civilian targets more than 50 Liv were
cut short in hor roza following a
missile strike Thursday a un field team
has been dispatched to the area to
collect information the appalling scenes
from the village of HOSA in the K region
of Ukraine underscore once again the
terrible price civilians are paying 20
months after Russia's Invasion Russia
claims it targets military
infrastructure concentrations of troops
and Ukrainian military leadership but
Ukrainian say these were regular
apartment buildings with regular
people I'm from the second floor
everything fell on me from the third she
says Rescuers pulled her out of a window
using a
ladder the UN says it has verified the
injuries of More Than 177,000 People
along with more than 9,000 civilian
deaths since the start of the full
invasion although the report released in
September notes the numbers are likely
considerably higher Crystal Ganson
Global News London she stood up to the
Iranian government fighting for equality
coming up the major victory for nagas
muhamadi and what the Iranian regime is
now being urged to
do imprisoned activist narus muhammadi
has won this year's Nobel Peace Prize
for her fight against the oppression of
women in Iran and the promotion of Human
Rights and freedom for all her win comes
a year after 22-year-old Masa am died
while in the custody of Iran's morality
police sparking unrest right across the
country n Gara reports in an award which
pays tribute to the courage of Iranian
woman narus mohamed's Nobel Peace Prize
is also a big win for the women's
movement it was a great boost of hope uh
because we need so much of it these days
the Norwegian Nobel committee called for
the Iranian regime to do the right thing
release her so she can be present to
receive this honor that we have a better
human rights situation in Iran an
engineer by trade and an activist since
the 90s Mohamed has campaigned for the
abolition of the death penalty and has
been imprisoned several times she's
currently in the notorious Evan prison
serving multiple sentences on charges
including spreading propaganda against
the state another sign that Iran's
regime is at war with its own people
this Toronto lawyer hopes the prize will
strengthen those who've been pushing
politicians and policy makers in Western
countries to do more it will be very
difficult now for Western politicians to
go and negotiate uh with a regime that
has a Nobel Peace Prize winner um in its
uh in its prisons the threat to women's
safety in Iran remains High rights
groups say one of the most recent
examples is a 16-year-old girl armita
gavant who is reportedly in a coma after
a confrontation on public transport for
not wearing a hijab we celebrate this
good news with heavy hearts in a
statement to the New York Times prepared
in advance in the event she won Mohammed
said she will never stop striving for
the realization of democracy freedom and
equality mohammed's husband watched from
their Paris home saying the prize will
embolden the fight for human
rights her son and daughter who've
campaigned for her Freedom say they're
proud the United Nations says hundreds
of people were killed in the Iranian
government Crackdown during the protest
which convulsed the country last year at
least 44 of them were minors mohamed's
prize brings another piece of
international attention to the ongoing
fight for freedom and Justice Nara
Global
News it's often referred to as the
children's Nobel Prize ahead the special
honor for a Canadian indigenous
[Music]
activist millions of children around the
world have chosen renowned Canadian
indigenous activist Cindy Blackstock as
the winner of the World children's
prize Blackstock was presented the award
by Queen Sylvia of Sweden for more than
three decades she's fought for the
rights of indigenous children empowering
them to become change makers we are now
joined by Cindy Blackstock just back
from Sweden in Ottawa uh Miss Blackstock
first of all congratulations for those
of us who have been following you for
years in your work this is so welld
deserved what does this mean to you this
award well it's an amazing honor because
this award is uh voted on by children
around the globe and as we look at that
we see that these children were learning
about first nation's children in Canada
and standing in solidarity for them so
it is a credit to the survivors who told
their truce the 60 scoop survivors who
sold their truce because children around
the world are now watching over their
grandchildren Canada has has such a dark
past when it comes to indigenous
relations and we just had the most
recent Truth and Reconciliation day how
are the steps we starting to take on
reconciliation being perceived out there
in the broader world I think people see
it in a cleare eyed way and that is that
um the the history of colonialism is
still with us and that there are
challenges right now for First Nations
maintain innate children that ought to
be solved because the solutions are on
the books and there's been choices are
being made about not acting on those
solutions to the detriment of children
so uh the good thing about orange shirt
day is that if the public puts pressure
on the government we've already seen
from the past that changes will happen
for kids and when we raise a generation
of First Nations M and innu children who
are healthy and proud that is going to
be one of the greatest legacies for the
country for the globe when you were a
child you grew up with a very unique
perspective you uh had an indigenous dad
and a white mother and you know when you
look back at children now and how
indigenous children are treated now as
opposed to when you were young what do
you see what I see is that the children
aren't alone anymore the First Nations
maintaining new it children aren't alone
anymore we're seeing uh other children
uh learning about residential schools
learning about uh colonization and
learning about the wonderful
contributions of the First Nations
maintained inent peoples in school and
that has prepared this generation to
really walk with respect uh with
indigenous peoples and I think that
that's a real example and should be an
inspiration for us to continue um the
other thing I'm seeing is that uh we
have got some amazing leaders out there
who are saying to the government that
we're not going to let you set the
timetable for remedying these injustices
if you don't do it voluntarily then
we'll have to take you to court and
that's just simply the way it's going to
have to be because children only get one
childhood and so we've got to be there
to make sure it's a special one I want
to get your thoughts on another big
development this week wab canoe being
chosen as Manitoba's first First Nations
Premier so what went through your mind
when you learned he'd been elected you
know what it is such a fabulous thing to
see so many first like Mary Simon being
appointed as governor general um to see
wob Cano elected as the first uh
indigenous Premier uh all all of these
things are really really sacred but it
only matters if you're first if there's
a second and a third and they have
worked so hard as many of our ancestors
did in the past to cut Trail so that
people like me could do better and live
a better quality of life and that's what
this is all about too is that all of us
including the children around the globe
are cutting some trail so that we can do
better for this generation of children
and the ones that
follow Cindy blck congratulations again
and thank you so much for your time and
your Insight as always thanks for having
me next the future of fungi how wild
mushrooms could be key to cleaning up
[Music]
ecosystems the world of mushrooms has
exploded in popularity and we're talking
about much more than what's been cooked
up in your kitchen our knowledge about
the future of fungi is growing and
Sophie Louie got a look at one-way
mushrooms are now being being used to
protect and preserve a fish habitat in
British Columbia
Sophie that's right there is evidence to
show that mushrooms could have the
potential to break down toxic oil
products and in northern BC a
conservation group is trying to see if
fungi could be the solution to a
longstanding problem involving both
salmon and railroad ties we got a rare
look at what's happening in a very
special area known as the sko water shed
the skina is BC's second largest salmon
Watershed and it's just over 54,000
square kilm which is bigger than
Switzerland Canadian National Railway
runs through this vital fish habitat it
has all five species of wild salmon we
also have the largest strain of wild
steel head in the world its ecosystem is
threatened by a chemical found in the
rail ties it's called creosote a toxic
substance that's been used since the the
1800s to preserve the wood when the ties
wear out they're removed from the tracks
and piled beside the railway by the
thousands sometimes for decades where
the chemicals can leech into the soil
they just leave them there the only time
they remove them is either they're going
to bring them elsewhere to bury them or
burn them and that just adds to the
problem it doesn't cure the problem the
US Environmental Protection Agency has
identified kote an oil-based product as
a carcinogen that may pose risks to fish
and inverte
I read all these case studies where they
used oyster mushrooms to clean up oil or
diesel or other fossil fuel spills in
the ground I thought it that can't
actually work can it the skina Coalition
set out to investigate teaming up with
local mushroom Farmers to test the
theory the Victorious mushroom was
turkey tail it munched up the creosote
and converted it back to its non-toxic
base elements we need to do a lot more
testing but what we know at the start is
that the worst we can do is we can make
these very toxic Railway ties
significantly less toxic an exciting
first step now the next one is moving
from the petri dish to the piles of ties
and that requires the cooperation of CN
Railway mcfa says CN has been contacted
but so far has not agreed to any further
development with the remediation project
it's amazing to think the lowly toad
stool might be the savior to help keep
our planet clean and safe for the future
far incredible Sophie Louie thank you
for that and you can watch Sophie's full
story tomorrow on the new reality to
learn how mushrooms are even being used
in music that's right right here on
global and that's global national for
this Friday night I'm Farin Naser
tonight's yourk Canada is St an de bellw
in Quebec until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good
night
[Music]
n